joining us now to reaction to all the
breaking news the author of the book why
we fight Fox News national security
strategist dr. Sebastian corker NRA TV
contributed damn Bungie no let's go to
the hysteria the fact that we actually
have the left X X fill in the blank
we're going to use the same words no
matter who Donald Trump picks is pretty
revealing but it's also 101 of the
Democratic Party smear the smart slander
lie racist sexist misogynist homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic dirty air water
killed children and grandma it's all the
same doctor Gorka we never get any
variation of that theme no we don't and
the really incredible thing is that
there isn't one indication amongst
anybody on the left that they really
understand that this is bad for them but
let them continue to do so there's no
realization that this does not play well
outside the bubble this this is great in
Hollywood this is great in New York this
is great in you know the DNC's cocktail
parties in Georgetown but it doesn't
resonate with the American people they
have a narrative which is ideologically
driven and whatever the President does
they will attack him and sooner or later
this will bear certain political
consequences for them my concern is that
they're upping the ante on the things
that are truly undemocratic yes they'll
smear us they smear you me whoever they
pick it to be the next Associate Justice
but the issue is when it comes to
harassment and the use of violence
there's no equivalent of an Tifa on the
right doesn't exist does not exist
there's no story of there's no story
there's that there's no story
like James Hodgkinson at the baseball
diamond just a few miles from where I'm
sitting we you don't have Republicans go
out with a hit list trying to kill
Democrat congressman guess which side
that happens on it happens on the left
I don't see any ideas from the left for
this election except we know what it is
open borders keep Obamacare they want
their crumbs back they want to impeach
Trump and they don't want the president
to get the Supreme Court nominee he
wants Dan can you name a single thing
that they are putting forward that helps
the American people because I'm not
hearing one single thing except oppose
oppose oppose no I'm glad you brought
this up you know Shawn Trump is Duncan
on the left and the media on a daily
basis now and they've gone from
derangement now to sheer panic and
here's why it's because of what you just
said precisely because of it the left
doesn't have an agenda Shawn there is
absolutely no popular mandate for
enormous government high taxes
government controlled health care and
complete government control of education
there is ZERO popular mandate for that
why does this Supreme Court thing matter
why have they now adjusted to their new
outrage campaign because Shawn
they can't legislate they have to
legislate from the bench where they only
have to convince one person who a judge
because they can't convince the American
people that this crap agenda they have
is real remember liberalism stinks for
liberals too don't forget that Shawn
it's me because what they can't get done
at the ballot box because the American
people would never buy it dr. Gork and
and I think damn Bungie knows right or
what they could never get done
legislatively without blowing up their
careers they try to use the courts for a
real judge respects that the legislative
branch has their job and their job is to
take the exact text and the
Constitution's exact text and see where
the line is it's not their job to
legislate no but but Dan's point is
incredibly important and it's not just
using activists in you know the 9th
Circuit Court or wherever it is you know
that's that's their short circuit to get
what they want but it's also the
intimidation the harassment I think you
know Pruitt's resignation is also a
function of they don't have a mandate
they don't have an agenda but that's why
it's so important what Cavanaugh said
last night he only made two substantive
statements he talked about the the women
in his life his inspiration but he only
two things judges don't legislate and a
SCOTUS judge interprets the Constitution
you know I'll give you the last word
damn buns you know it's very very
obvious how the left is now speaks with
one voice that's why those six senators
they have told the line of Chuck Schumer
not their constituents Sean Nate they
think like the Borg and Star Trek they
think with a hive mind they're not
independent entrepreneurs like
conservatives and that's why this attack
strategy can sometimes works for them
they think with a hive mind they're not
independent really well said both of you
all right thank you both